hello everyone and welcome to this bonus
video here on firm learning
and the reason that i do this video is
that a couple of days ago
it was actually my one year anniversary
of
doing this channel i uploaded the first
video on this channel on january 17th of
2020
and since then the growth for sure
surprised me
so i got over 75 000 subscribers in the
first
year of doing this channel here on
youtube so over the last months i got
several people asking me okay
how did you do it how does it work you
have any insights
on how to grow your youtube channel
faster so in this video i will show you
the actual real back end
of my youtube analytics of firm learning
i will show you how the growth
looked like how it happened over time
and i trust there are some good
learnings to be drawn from that
and even if you don't have your own
youtube channel and also not interested
in starting one anytime soon i do
believe it is very worthwhile to
understand this whole system and
better to understand a bit better how
youtube actually works
how it promotes the videos how this
growth actually happens so hang in here
with me i promise there are some good
learnings to be taken out from this so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning my name is
heinrich and on my channel i want to
help you to become successful in
the first years of your career but
before we look into the backend
guys i need to ask you something i do
not understand this as you know i do my
very best to answer every single comment
that you write me
but for whatever reason pretty much
since the very start of this
channel i keep getting this comment get
into that chopper
guys what are you even talking about
what is this all about i don't get it
whatever guys let's now jump into the
youtube analytics and let's check it out
this is my youtube analytics backend
this is what i
see if i look into the statistics of my
channel and now i wanted to show you the
channel statistics from the very
beginning
because even though the first video that
i published i believe it was on january
17th
i already made this channel quite some
time before i believe apparently here it
was
may 28 of 2018 and the reason was that
at that time
already i had the idea that maybe at
some point in the future i wanted to do
something like that i wanted to talk
about consulting contents like that
and around this time i also created this
slide writing course so some of you
maybe know
if you don't know it check it out a link
in the video description so i had the
idea maybe let me make something bigger
out of it the bigger platform
and this was why i created this youtube
channel initially
in the beginning i uploaded one video to
this channel
it was i believe a snippet from this
course i didn't do any advertisement or
whatever
what you hear you can see that pretty
much just randomly by youtube promoting
this one video i got 267 views
and a total of three subscribers
so i was pretty much starting from zero
when on january 17th i was starting the
channel and uploading the real video
so let's now look into the growth really
month by month how all of this
looked like so let me now select as a
starting point
january of 2020 because this is when
this really started when i
just started uploading the videos so
this is now the month that is selected
january 2020
so what you can see here indeed that on
january 17th
i uploaded two videos so a little
introduction and then the first video
here
and since then i pretty much started
doing one video
every single month so then
only due to this one and a half thousand
views
this is what i got and if you look here
into the subscribers
you see that already got a couple of
subscribers pretty much 224
only after this half a month and the
reason was my promotion
strategy in the very beginning was that
i was joining
facebook groups student facebook groups
and they're pretty much
promoting the channel just leaving a
little message talking about the channel
and this really helped me to to get it
all going to get it started
to know what this is all about so let's
now look into february
one month further how did this develop
here again
pretty much at this level so you see
that after some time or was it
565 subscribers so after one and a half
month
again my main growth strategy was this
whole
facebook game just joining facebook
groups mainly student groups in facebook
and then just talking about it
so let's continue march so again at some
point i stopped doing all of this with
the facebook promotions and you see that
the views also plummeted
i believe there was a period of one or
two weeks probably this was
this little spike where i tried out
paid youtube ads right so i tried out to
set up a little ad campaign
wherefore i believe it was five euro per
day
for a couple of days i was just trying
to promote a video and just check what
that was doing
but as you can see here the results were
pretty underwhelming so these are the
views
but if you now compare this to the
subscribers you see that even though
there were some views i did not get
hardly any subscribers from that right
so then i also stopped doing it
because i didn't see any results from it
whatsoever
so this was march now let's move to
april
and here in april now you see that
suddenly these subscribers start to
to increase a bit more organically and
then end of april was apparently also
when i hit
the 1000 subscribers you know if you
look into the views again you see now
that suddenly
there is a bit of an let's see organic
growth going on that
you know the the views are starting to
slightly increase here without me really
doing anything
let's look into may again this trend was
further increasing in may right and now
you can see that this channel
started kind of to organically pick up
some steam pick up some action
now but still slow and steady growth now
there was
june let's see how june looked like you
know the views the views are now
organically really increasing
spiking here so very good development
organic development but still of course
on a low level
now next july and in july you see that
suddenly there was a spike here suddenly
there was a spike in the views
and this was indeed from this video this
video i applied to mckinsey with this cv
that really got picked up by the
algorithm this was the first time that i
really got some traction organic
traction from the youtube algorithm
that helped to move the whole channel to
the next level
and this was also i believe shortly
after that i also hit my 4
000 hours of watch time i believe you
can see this
here so now at this point i was at 5 600
and as you know in order to be to be
part of the youtube partner program and
be able to earn some money with youtube
you need 4 000 hours of watch time so
this was
pretty much this period when i when i
made this
and of course if you look into the
subscribers this was also the met by
that one day
peak day 190 subscribers that i got
so pretty crazy increase in the channel
growth but then it got
even more crazy because then in august
if you look here into the numbers
suddenly there was another very big
movement so this peak here
was the peak that we saw earlier and it
pretty much
almost 10x right from here and what was
the reason again
it was this video which performed very
very strongly
still not the most viewing video on my
channel but then also the other two next
videos especially this video that was
coming next
also doing very well and then sustaining
this over time
and this was then really also met by the
subscriber numbers where i then suddenly
was jumping to 32
000 subscribers and at the peak there
was only one day where i got 1800
subscribers and i believe this is really
an important lesson if you want to
understand youtube growth
because youtube growth is always a step
function
it comes in little explosions so yes
there will be some organic movement
where you slowly accrue subscribers over
time
but then it just takes this one video
this one or two videos
that for whatever reason get picked up
by the algorithm
and that then caterpied your whole
channel to the next level
and then what is also typical you can
see it here then after some time
this of course decreases after some time
your video was seen by most of the
people who
wanted to see and then youtube stops
further promoting this and now this is
of course a trend
that you can see to continue if you know
look also in the september if you go one
month further
it now slowly starts to decrease to go
down again
here also in the subscribers the
subscribers and now if we
go to october you can really see how now
this was
back down again right so this level here
in subscribers but here also in views
it's significantly decreased though of
course while this level is much lower
than this
if you compare it to these levels
initially of course this is
a big multiple of what was here then of
course this will help you to now
pretty much get your channel to the next
level and then it continued this way
now let's look into november what
happened here because what you see in
november is that again here i was
lucky and privileged enough to have
another video which really performed
well
it was this how to take notes for work
video which was picked up by the
algorithm again you see here directly
the views
going up you see the subscribers going
up here again
but again then similar to what we've
seen before this time now even
quicker that then this was also
decreasing
again after some time so but now end of
december i was
in pretty much 11 and a half months at
72 subscribers
0.8 and then the views this is also what
you see here
is that it is slowing down again and now
if you look at the very end pretty much
until
today so now the latest figures you can
see that
the views are now again on this lower
level where they are stabilizing this is
now the new level which is slightly
higher than this level
so again i believe the takeaway here is
that youtube growth
comes in steps it's a step function only
takes one or two videos
to really catapult your channel to the
next level and then hopefully
after you come down from the level again
because yes this will happen as well
then hopefully at the time your baseline
will increase right you will stay at a
new level which will establish itself
as the new normal for you so my
recommendation really is if you are
thinking about starting a youtube
channel
do not be discouraged if in the first
months you don't see much traction
so you see this was really the first
half year where almost
nothing happened of course relative to
these peaks that are so here i mean at
the time i was of course super lucky and
super
satisfied with the views that i got
right but now then suddenly it just
takes this first video which apparently
also sent a good signal to the algorithm
then here the next videos which
catapulted it even higher
and then now you're really in need of
these occasional videos which will
really perform well
just to move you up the curve to move
you to the next level
so i'm super excited to see how this
growth will continue now over the new
year 2021
i for sure have lots of great videos
planned for you i get several messages
every single day also on instagram of
people telling me that they got that job
at that big four at that mbb consulting
firm and that they believed that these
videos really had them
so of course this makes me super happy
this alone is a reason enough to
continue doing this so thank you so much
for supporting this channel to be here
with me from the beginning
and let's continue this journey together
here in this new year so hope you found
this insightful and as always if you
have any
question just leave me a comment below
in the comment section and as you know i
will do my very best to answer every
single comment that you write if you
took any value out of this at all please
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm
and of course subscribe to my channel to
stay up to date on all my content
so if you want to see more from me
follow me on instagram my handle is firm
learning
and also have a mailing list you can
sign up to that via the video
description so now i want to say thank
you to all the members off i'm learning
you're really helping a lot
this is really a significant
contribution to the course of this
channel so if you want to become a
member as well hit the join button next
to the subscribe button to learn what
it's all about i'm releasing new videos
every single saturday and sometimes
little bonus videos like this one so
looking forward to see all of you next
saturday
thank you for hanging along here with me
all the best to you
goodbye heineken from learning here
the chopper